vous êtes sur france 24 et vous avez
raison bienvenue dans votre journal de
l'afrique à la une ce soir la tacc de
djihadistes dans le nord-est du mali à
ménaka plusieurs dizaines de civils et
d'anciens membres de msa ont été tués
c'est un mouvement issu de l'ex
rébellion touareg est signataire de
l'accord pour la paix dans le nord du
mali analyse à suivre dans ce journal
l'inflation alimentaire que l'on observe
partout dans le monde n'est pas renier
pas le continent africain le ghana par
exemple a vu ses prix augmenter depuis
le 15 pour cent en février son plus haut
niveau depuis six ans focus dans une
boulangerie dakar d'accra qui joue sa
survie en septembre crise nous irons en
rdc pour vous parler du problème
récurrent des constructions anarchiques
qui entraînent des drames une vingtaine
de personnes sont mortes le mois dernier
à cause de la chute d'un câble de haute
tension sur un marché kinshasa
reportage à suivre de nos correspondants
on ouvre ce journal par cette attaque de
djihadistes dans le nord-est du mali
parmi les victimes on compte plusieurs
dizaines de civils et les combattants du
mouvement pour le salut de l'azawad le
msa est issu de l'ex rébellion touareg
signataires de l'accord de paix dit
d'alger signés en 2015 suivez les
explications de l'autre spécialiste des
mouvements dialyse oici menace
un an exactement il ya eu le même genre
d' attaque mais un peu plus au sud de la
zone qui est concerné aujourd'hui donc
on a une carte on pourra le voir est
tout a démarré on veut dire dans
l'assassinât d'un chef touareg du msa ce
qui a fait que les touareg ont interdit
à ceux qui amènent des des vivres aux
jihadistes l'accès à la ville de tam à
lattes et puis crescendo sarrassat à
monter jusqu'au 5 c'est habituel il ya
un an ils se sont battus un drame
locales ici donc mais le saint qui a eu
des audio donc des djihadistes de l'état
islamique avec une fatwa qui rendait le
sens des dao sac donc les touareg dos
sac est licite et la prise de leur
bétail légale à leurs yeux bien sûr donc
le 5 aussi tout le bétail qui a été là
donc c'est une zone de transit ans a été
pris par les dialyses de l'état
islamique et puis le 8 et se sont
attaqués à ce village de tamelaht ils
l'ont pris puis ils ont attendu que le
msa donc les touareg vienne enterrer les
corps pour les attaquer à nouveau et là
ils ont tué deux commandants importants
du hamas a puis l'ont confié ils se sont
attaqués à la ville et dingxi nan là
c'était avant-hier qu'ils ont pris la
ville c'est une ville qui est plutôt
connu pour ses magasins pour ces marchés
etc ils ont tout brûlé ils ont tout volé
et on sent en tout cas d'après plusieurs
sources locales je peux avoir le porte
parole du hamas a le chef du hamas à qui
m'a dit non c'est habituel mais d'après
plusieurs sources locales sur zone on
sent qu'on est montée d'un cran en tout
cas dans ce dans ce conflit sachant
qu'aujourd'hui le msa donc cette faction
touag et sa seule pardon face à l' état
islamique dans cette zone en particulier
et ils ont été eux mêmes est surpris on
va dire par le nombre d'assaillants a
cette fois ci qui rappelle encore une
fois les combats par exemple entre
al-qaïda et l'état islamique plus au sud
dans sa zone des batailles rangées est
organisée avec une
tactique beaucoup plus élaboré on va
dire que juste du vol de bétail ou de l'
attaque contre les communautés comme ce
fut le cas dans cette zone là donc on
sent que qu'on est montée d'un cran et
c'est très significatif aujourd'hui
dans ce contexte le commandant de la
force française barkan a tenu à préciser
que la france
maintiendrait sa base aérienne et dément
en redéploiement au niger on écoute le
général laurent michaud
je n'ai pas de se repositionner
il s'agit de se retirer du mali et les
contingents
italiens suédois français plupart du
mali vont rentrer en europe très
clairement il y à un dispositif qui sera
adapté peut-être niger sur la demande
des autorités militaires nigériennes je
ne sais pas après seulement peut-être
qu'il y aura des demandes nigérienne
pour continuer ce que nous faisons déjà
côte à côte dans le diktat aux nigériens
de soldats français sont engagés dans
l'étape obligée rien pour aider au
contrôle de ces zones contestées et
permanent des populations ne peut-être
que nous poursuivrons cette action si
les nigériens le souhaitent peut-être
qu'il y aura d'autres choses mais il ya
absolument pas de redéploiement de repos
uniquement de bach
une délégation conduite par le ministre
malien des affaires étrangères est
arrivé ce vendredi matin à nouakchott en
cause la disparition de plusieurs
mauritanien dans la zone frontalière la
mauritanie accusent l'armée malienne
d'actes criminels récurrent sur son sol
de son côté les autorités maliennes
condamne ces actes et annonce
l'ouverture d'une enquête
on passe au reste de l'actualité
africaine en bref et en images
au moins 17 civils ont été tués dans de
nouveaux affrontements tribaux darfour
ces décès portent à une quarantaine le
bilan des morts et en une semaine de
combats entre les tribus au darfour les
accusant de cette attaque sont les
janjawid des miliciens arabes dont les
milliers sont intégrés à présent au
pouvoir militaire en place depuis les
putschs d'octobre 2021
cette information politique en guinée
qui défraie la chronique le parti de
l'ancien président déchu alpha condé a
un nouveau chef il s'agit de son ancien
premier ministre ibrahima kassory fofana
qui va tenir les rênes du rpg ce dernier
assure avoir été désigné par une lettre
manuscrite ou d'alpha condé qui lui est
en convalescence abou dhabi une
information sur laquelle des cadres du
parti émettent des réserves
c'est le retour des sourires au kenya
les autorités ont annoncé la fin du port
du masque obligatoire dans les lieux
publics et plus besoin de tests pcr
négatif pour les voyageurs entièrement
vacciner le pays enregistre un taux de
contamination comme u19 inférieure à 1%
au total néanmoins 5644 personnes sont
mortes plus ducobu sur plus de 300 mille
cas de contamination au kenya depuis
2020 selon les chiffres officiels
op art hogan à eau depuis des mois les
habitants subissent une inflation
croissante et en février elle a atteint
son plus haut niveau en six ans les
produits de première nécessité sont
concernés comme la farine la margarine
l'eau l'une des principales raisons de
cette hausse et le co vide qui a inventé
les importations la guerre en ukraine
risque d'empirer l'inflation
illustration de cette crise avec une
boulangerie d'accra en affaires depuis
25 ans sur les cibles
de la farine et de l'eau d'abord puis de
la margarine des ingrédients nécessaires
pour préparer le pain des produits dont
le prix explosent au ghana l'inflation a
encore battu des records en février
ce boulanger a annoncé cette affaire il
ya 25 ans avec un ami d'enfance qui de
son côté distribuer les fournées
l'inflation due en partie aux ruptures
d'approvisionnement pendant le coc vide
les a mis en grande difficulté
ils ne peuvent même pas augmenter le
prix du pain cet interdit et vendre des
pins plus petit serait mal vu nous
recevoir tous
liquigas eyes of the break d'un moment
du big easy to you try to une critique
d'un an et demi comme c'est probable
et demi comme ce sens évoqué et via
vingré sites analogues et éthiques les
deux amis se sont endettés et risquent
de mettre la clé sous la porte
hamadan hier à ma bonne braise gagner
des
faca nommé petite emma
25 ans qu'il se lève à 3h du matin le
travail est pénible mais la boulangerie
était leur rêve devenu réalité et qui
risque maintenant de disparaître
on part à kinshasa au début février une
vingtaine de personnes sont mortes
électrocutées après la chute d'un câble
à haute tension sur un marché ce drame a
mis en lumière un problème récurrent
dans la capitale congolaise celui des
constructions anarchiques des dizaines
de milliers de personnes habitent à
proximité d'une ligne électrique d'une
rivière ou d'un chemin de fer ce qui les
met en danger les autorités dénoncent
l'insuffisance des qui moi mais l'état
est également pointée du doigt oui ce
reportage de clément bonnes roues et je
lui a du goût
quand cet urbaniste parcourent les rues
de kinshasa c'est toujours le même
constat de nombreux bâtiments sont
construits en violation des règles
d'urbanisme
exemple avec cette église dans le
quartier de vandales qui se situe juste
en dessous d'une ligne à haute tension
selon la réglementation
on ne peut pas construire des maisons
sous la ligne à haute tension il ya une
marge les marges et la loi a pris vie et
la marge et l'est des 50 m selon les
autorités locales 40 % des constructions
à kinshasa sont anarchique c'est à dire
qu'elles ne respectent pas les règles
d'urbanisme dans le quartier voisin de
yolo des habitants ont construit leur
maison à quelques mètres d'une rivière
plusieurs fois par an les pluies font
déborder le cours d'eau
lorsqu'il ya de fortes pluies l'eau
atteint ce niveau josé a acheté son
terrain il ya plus de dix ans il affirme
qu'il n'était pas au courant des
démarches à suivre avant de faire
construire sa maison il ya un chef des
casques et l'office y est c'est pas pire
on m'a donné tellement le papier un
papier l'affiché partiel et je suis pas
aller ailleurs ou soit sociétés et à des
motorisations de de construction like
parce que pour jouer le piana les
autorités ont aussi leur part de
responsabilités en autorisant la vente
de terrains non constructibles en plein
coeur de kinshasa set fut cela elle est
aux toilettes dans une zone l'enap
offrir c'est là que les problèmes
commencent l'autorité elle-même enfreint
la loi parce que tout ce document qui
sont données ces documents sont octroyés
au nom de l'état le gouvernement
congolais promet de son côté de
renforcer les contrôles pour les
habitants et pour les agents de l'état
un autre dispositif juridique qui n'est
pas négligeable au guichet unique
pour le permis
de construire à ces moments là tous ceux
qui veulent construire savent quoi ils
ne vont plus à l'est à gauche à droite
et devront aller toquer à une seule
porte en attendant le gouvernement a
annoncé des sanctions plus sévères et
promet que tout bâtiment construit sans
autorisation sera systématiquement
démoli
direction l'ouganda où la première ferme
de cannabis qui avait ouvert ses portes
en 2018 a livré sa toute première
production au marché européen et
pourtant cultiver cette plante et l'a
consommée est normalement illégale dans
le pays seule une compagnie a pour le
moment obtenu la permission de faire
pousser mais uniquement pour l'exporter
la transformer en médicament
l'augmentation de la demande mondiale en
europe et en amérique du nord est une
aubaine pour l'économie ougandaise qui
veut s'imposer sur ce marché mondial en
pleine croissance reportage de ciment
wohlfarth
cette ferme landaise est la seule
autorisée à produire du cannabis à visée
thérapeutique
ici des centaines de pieds pousse sur
trente mille mètres carrés dans un
environnement étroitement contrôlés on
va récolter ses plans pour les trois
prochaines semaines et tout sera
exportée à l'origine du projet une
entreprise israélienne s'est allié à un
partenaire local pour créer industriel
globus et démarrer cette activité en
2018 l'organisation a été séduite par
les caractéristiques du pays quant à une
altitude plus tôt mais également situé
sur l'équateur pas d'hiver pas de gel
ensoleillement constants tous les
ingrédients sont réunis pour faire
pousser cette plante
ici les travailleurs sont très qualifiés
bien formés et la main d'oeuvre est un
cheikh d'une centaine d'employés de la
région travaillent ici pour un salaire
de 150 à 450 euros bien supérieur aux
revenus moyens
à étudier l'agriculture à kampala c'est
ici qu'elle a trouvé son premier emploi
la plupart des personnes avec qui je
travaille ici avant elle était chez elle
à ne rien faire quand la compagnie s'est
installé en augmentant elles ont une
opportunité de commencer à travailler
maintenant les gens des belles maisons
ils ont plein de projets grâce à leur
salaire qu'ils obtiennent islamique ce
dernier thing from 10 forme pourtant à
ce jour la plantation et la consommation
de cannabis reste illégal pour toutes
les autres entreprises et les
particuliers une situation de monopole
critiqué par certains experts aux freins
donc nous avons conseillé près de 25
organisations locales et internationales
qui veulent obtenir le permis pour
cultiver de la marijuana à des fins
commerciales
j'ai malheureusement aucune d'entre
elles de l'homme
s'inquiète si l'ouganda veut vraiment
accédé au statut de pays à revenu
intermédiaire l'année prochaine la
légalisation pour les petits producteurs
et sa distribution sur le marché sont le
moyen d'y parvenir le groupe industriel
globus exporte déjà à lui seul jusqu'à
cinq tonnes de cannabis par an et les
chiffres pourraient encore augmenter la
demande ne cesse de croître en europe et
en amérique du nord d'année en année
elle s'est ainsi comme en refermant ce
journal l'afrique merci à tous ceux qui
nous ont suivis de ménaka kinshasa en
passant par accra restez avec nous car
l'actualité continue sur france 24
[Musique]